This photograph here,
you're probably thinking,
why have I shown you a picture of a sort
of a suburban street happens to be in
Blackpool,
which is quite interesting for this
discussion because what it shows us a
big crack that goes just underneath my
name there and that crack was very
famous in Blackpool for a short time
because it purportedly appeared after an
earthquake which was related to fracking
rather nearby it's fracking for shale
gas,
hydraulic fracturing,
and people said that the fractured
appeared the crack it appeared in the
bridge and people also said that the
motorbikes had fallen over and that and
that traffic lights stopped working and
things like that.
And a lot of people said yes,
the crack appeared and it was caused by
the fracking.
Now the BGS detected this earthquake and
our view was there's no way that the
energy of the earthquake could have
caused that crack.
Then.
And in fact,
if you read the article which was
attached to this photograph,
if you've got knocked down to the
bottom,
it said an old black poor man said.
In fact that crack has been there since
1972.
So,
uh,
but this,
this characterizes the argument of shale
gas that there's an awful lot of stuff
going on which you can't tell is true or
false and this,
it's rather got worse.
And unfortunately this is a game,
Blackpool,
and uh,
there are people saying on websites that
Blackpool at the coast of backfill is at
risk of sinking below sea level and our
seat,
a sea defenses will have to be rebuilt.
Essentially.
There is no foundation whatsoever to
this.
It simply won't happen.